the kids are back to school and that
means time to get those lunches ready
and if there is
anyone that can make a lunch look and
taste amazing it's the woman who says
let's make some lunch for my kids yes
you know her for tick tock she is the
bento box queen jessica woo
welcome hi thanks for having me and who
did we bring today what is your name
my name is adeline adeline so you are
the recipient of these amazing lunches
are you not
yes oh how jealous are your friends i
don't know
i told her i'd be looking at her lunch
every single day all right so
let's make some lunch for your kids what
are we going to make today jessica today
we're going to do a tuna
kimchi kim pop roll okay so do i get to
help make this yes we come right over
here okay i started yours out
um we have some seaweed kim rice
and then we're gonna make our tuna
mixture so this is tuna
squeeze in a little bit of this is
japanese mayo ooh
what's the difference between a little
bit more yeah japanese mayo and regular
mayo
this is probably better isn't it to me
it has
kind of a little bit of like a
horseradish taste to it so
um yeah it just kind of gives it a kick
okay
we got that in there pepper oh man
you've got 5.4 million followers on tick
tock how did this happen
um just by doing a live stream you just
thought one day was it during the
pandemic and you thought hey let's
just make some lunch for my kids um well
i've been making her lunch for
almost five years now so this is just
kind of something i did
and then my sister actually was like hey
you should
record your your kids yeah because
they're you know they're cute
and i never thought that it would yeah
it would turn into this crazy and you
live here in las vegas
okay we just put the tuna on we got some
kimchi
which i love okay so now what
okay so now we're gonna use this bamboo
i'm gonna start it off for you okay
do you like kimchi yes you do is it one
of your favorite
oh it's delicious okay so we're just
gonna keep rolling this
okay so i just take it with the take
this yep and
roll you can roll it and leave a little
bit of space at the end i'm going to add
some rice
does that make it sticky yep okay see
we're getting all the tips and tricks
yeah i i made bologna and cheese for my
kids that's not very good
okay let me help you right here okay
we're gonna roll this up it's not gonna
look as good as yours but we're gonna
try we're getting there and then we're
just gonna
roll it again okay and seal it up seal
it
up so kimbap rolls are great for lunch
because you can basically add
any of your favorite meats like you can
use spam
poo gogi you can add any vegetables in
there so
take it out yep we're good here oops
we've got less than a minute but i know
you can make this look good okay i've
seen the videos
and on tick tock and instagram where can
people follow you if they want great
ideas
um um sully jessica it's my first and
middle name
s-u-l-h-e-e-j-e-s-s-i-c-a
and there we go all right so then we
just add those in there yeah
put them really pretty and look at that
now you're gonna make another dish for
us
on our social so make sure you follow
las vegas now on social
but this looks amazing do you want to be
my taste tester
okay okay pick one all right let's try
this one see if it's good
i made it myself
can we do it let's let's do it on three
one two
three let's make some lunch for my kids
hopefully you jc that is fantastic thank
you guys